tonight tonight baby let's let's address
this first yeah no preseason right out
of the gates they're dropping the teams
on to the field it's texans chiefs what
do we expect just by virtue of the fact
that this is the first time they're
putting their uniforms on and going out
onto a field and facing an opponent all
year long well i think you're going to
see some sloppiness for sure i mean you
know the one thing like we talked about
yesterday i know with a lot with tony
dungy rodney harris and miss tackling
you know the fact that one we didn't
have preseason games two i think coaches
were a little scared to just go all out
all the time during training camp
because they didn't want player they
wanted to keep their 53 man roster
intact because hey we got a a game that
really counts to start the year so i had
a i would have a hard time thinking
tackling's going to be perfect that way
the other thing i'll say that that i
expect to play a factor in this is
conditioning you know part of the
pre-season is you know realizing how to
deal with your emotions and ramping up
for the game and the nerves of it and
everything like that and then the
intensity of oh wow okay i haven't you
know turned up the intensity like this
in any training camp practice they've
been intense but they haven't been like
this where i'm nervous my coach is
yelling at me the quarterback's barking
signals at me and oh yeah i got this big
dude who's mean and angry in front of me
and i gotta stop him so that to me will
be another big factor in the football
game overall i look at it like offenses
have advantage here mike i really do
throughout the nfl in a week like this
the passers the catchers you know
they've been throwing and catching the
football all spring doing that type of
stuff we saw brady in tampa and all that
so that that to me i expect
a lot of passing yards and i i think
that's where i expect tonight in general
we could see a lot of big-time explosive
pass plays there but these two
quarterbacks and the weapons they have
and that was a point that somebody made
yesterday when we were having our
meetings and our rehearsals for
tonight's pregame show the idea that
what we saw
was offenses gathering for these
practices right you don't see defenses
gathering
what do you do as
a a voluntary get together on a high
school field in texas what do you do as
defensive players by yourselves you got
to have an offense there
to try to defend against in order to
meaningfully practice but the offense
can run through their plays can run
through their rhythm and their timing
and and work it all out and they were
doing it but the defenses weren't so
that's another reason and the tackling
has been an issue for the last 10 years
chris ever since they
adjusted the cba in 2011 to dramatically
reduce padded practices the intensity of
the off-season and training camp all
about taking away the opportunities and
the occasions for guys to get head
injuries that's what it was all about
yeah so now guys don't know how to
tackle and we're going to be for the
first time in a live tackling situation
i'd love to know how many teams actually
had tackling to the ground this year
during the pre-season my guess is not
many and they did probably didn't do it
very often no not at all you might have
got you know thud type practices hey
contact you know stop the ball carrier
but then let him go and maybe let him
finish the run to where he can you know
get used to running 20 yards down the
field all those type of things going to
the ground in a normal year
is very rare to where only a handful of
teams in the league would really tackle
to the ground during training camp so
that doesn't go on normally let alone a
year like this where of course we can't
forget you know we saw at the start of
training camp guys were were getting
hurt left and right to where these
coaches had to pull back the reins a
little bit and be hey we got to get
these guys in shape first here before we
get too intense
so
uh yeah i think it's certainly going to
be a problem mike i'm glad you brought
up 2011 because i think again there's
some correlation there and we talked
about the pass catchers we had three
three 5 000 yard passers that year you
know the offenses kind of hit the ground
running and the defenses took a little
while to get their feet underneath them
i think that you could see some you know
similarities there
hey and not to get ahead of ourselves
are we talking about cam newton tomorrow
but uh
he was a rookie in 2011 without the
benefit of an off-season program and he
came in and he went
from the get-go right so uh yeah you
know we always think that the defense is
a little bit ahead of the offense going
into a normal season this may be one of
those abnormal seasons where the offense
is ahead of the defense and let's start
with the team whose offense ultimately
was way ahead of the houston defense in
the playoffs last year
spotting the texans 24 nothing and then
outscoring them the rest of the way
51
to 7.
51-7
and look if you're the texans i don't
know how you even show up
i mean maybe it's good that they've been
distracted by the pandemic and
everything else because otherwise you're
sitting around saying really we got to
go back there 51 to 7 and endure that
again do we expect it to be any
different when the chiefs have the ball
tonight well uh no i'm not going to say
that i expect it to be a whole lot
different i think you're going to see a
lot of points and a lot of yards from
the kansas city chiefs offense you know
first off the houston texans defense
you know it was it was nothing to write
home about last year they weren't good
at stopping the run they weren't good at
stopping the pass so there's a lot of
questions there i think in the secondary
in general just about will those guys
perform be able to match up with
receivers on a week-to-week basis and
then you know we've talked about it a
little too with the houston texans they
lost the dj reader you know j.j watts
had the injury bug you know getting to
this point of his career can he stay
healthy that's imperative because he's
really one of the only few difference
makers they have in the front seven so
i know i don't expect the houston texans
to slow down kansas city a whole lot
tonight
yeah i don't either and i think the
question's going to become can they
outscore them we'll talk about when the
texans have the ball coming up but let's
focus a little bit more on this kansas
city offense with the new rookie running
back clyde that's where we got to go for
damien williams david williams opted out
i remember when they drafted edward
solaire
and brett veach initially said damian
williams is the starter they're going to
share the load and i thought well as the
season goes on when they realized clyde
edwards hilaire is a lot better than
damian williams all due respect they
wouldn't have used a first round pick on
exactly clyde edwards hillary if they
didn't think that that's right that
we'll see more of him then now we're
going to see a lot of them right out of
the gates now that you know they they
i'm told had interest in adrian peterson
which makes me wonder how they feel
about the backup but you know what if
they have concerns about the backup what
does that mean that means more work for
the starter yeah right until they can
find a backup they feel good about clyde
ebersoler is our guy and i i feel like
that there's been a ton of hype there's
been a ton of expectation but i rewind
to the opening game of the season three
years ago when kareem hunt made his
debut as a rookie and had a huge night
after fumbling on his first carry of his
nfl career had a huge night in new
england to help fuel the chiefs to a
blowout win over the new england
patriots well not really a blowout but
anytime you beat the patriots in new
england it's kind of feels like a
blowout but chief's got it done that
night and a rookie running back got it
done is a rookie running back going to
get it done tonight i think so i just i
think he'll have every bit of a piece of
the offense just like we saw kareem hunt
start if not more because i think you
could argue clyde edwards hilaire coming
from you know lsu and that west coast
offense and he's in the same offense now
again to where
i would think he's got a pretty good
grasp of the offense and especially you
know all the things he did in the past
game but to me
you know this is where kansas city's
become deadly this is why you know this
is why
they're special
good offensive line okay i you know i
will say this i worry about bad
offensive lines we didn't really hit on
that but i worry about that but forget
it i won't get to that good offensive
line awesome receivers that can attack
downfield kelsey works the middle of the
field the teams that we've seen have
success against the kansas city chiefs
on defense play deep dropping zones and
take away those aggressive plays that
dynamic guy in my opinion is going to
change with with clyde edward solaire
because now between the screen game and
whoa you want to give this guy that much
space one-on-one with a linebacker or
somebody that's less than him as an
athlete
he's going to make people look silly in
those scenarios and i think that's going
to make defenses have to kind of
reevaluate how they want to approach
kansas city and it makes them almost
indefensible in in my opinion
and just to rewind back again to 2017 to
put in perspective the extent to which
the chiefs leaned on a rookie running
back right out of the gates
at a big
moment in new england to start the
season it was to 27. that's a blowout
patriots by 15 at home that's a blow up
yes kareem hunt had 148 yards rushing
that night on 17 carries 8.7 yards per
carry and 98 yards receiving on five
catches that's 246 yards from scrimmage
and three touchdowns right out of the
gates for a guy who had none of the
anticipation that clyde edward solaire
is bringing to the table going against a
defense
slightly better than the houston texans
slightly better i'd say so
uh now look look that was a game that
the patriots were supposed to win it's
so rare for the team that is hoisting
the banner to lose and it was a stunner
it was a shocker i remember being there
thinking oh my god you know so it's a
different set of circumstances this time
around the chiefs are the ones who are
being hunted but still it's andy reid
you got patrick mahomes the question is
how are you designing this game plan are
you going to let patrick holmes throw
the ball down the field like he always
does so well or do you take what's there
and will it be plenty of opportunities
underneath because defenses are obsessed
with not getting burned by tyree kill
sammy watkins and travis kelsey so it
very well could be that the chiefs have
designed something tonight that will
allow edward tulare to ring up the kind
of numbers it would be
it would be ridiculous for him to have
three touchdowns and 246 yards from
scrimmage but kareem hunt did it three
years ago i know so it wouldn't be crazy
if it happened nothing's crazy with this
offense i mean no there there's i mean
the sky's the limit with them
we know
and then we know added on to that with
andy reid and time off whether it's bye
weeks or first games i mean he's the mad
scientist this way this is why i think
they're scary too because you know i
know you've heard me say the pressure's
off so now he might have been like oh i
don't know if i want to try this this
might but i want a super bowl hey i'm
going to do it the hell with it this
quarterback he'll pull it off tyreek
will figure it out
i just think it's gonna embolden them to
where it's gonna be scary that way and
mike you know you brought up the rushing
uh stats too
with kareem hun in new england i think
that's a very real thing too as well
it's the same
same type of thought oh we're worried
about the deep pass game oh draw play oh
you know little sprint out here you go
clyde edwards hilaire now he's on the
edge whatever it may be it's another
element that you just have to worry
about and it's going to be hard to
defend this formula in my opinion uh
with the way andy calls plays and the
talent they have
before we flip over to the texans
offense who is it on the texans defense
that we really can rely on to do so you
know j.j watt three-time defensive
player of the year when he's healthy
he's dominant it just feels like he
doesn't have
yes the supporting cast around him that
maybe he once did right i think so you
know the clown clowney's not there
whitney merciless is no longer in the
prime of his career whitney merciless is
the guy i look at to be like hey
you know he's got to be that next
disrupter and he's capable of that he's
always you know i think last year he
flirted with double digit sacks
but yes there's no marquee names other
than jj watt or a guy that you can look
at right now and go well i can depend on
him to make a play on the defensive side
of the ball and you know i know we're
going to flip it around here in a second
kansas city's defense is not exactly the
steel curtain but they got guys like
that they got a guy at each level where
you can go oh he can make a play and
kind of change the game so you better
watch out for him uh and yeah i think
that's a big question about this this
texans football team all the way is the
defense in general and have they
improved from last year and who is going
to step up and you know take take the
reins and be a playmaker for them
and once the chiefs dropped the hammer
last year on the tech since travis
kelsey had three touchdowns as part of
that comeback and who's going to cover
travis kelsey you guys had 1200
receiving yards well we're straight
seasons yeah who's gonna who's gonna do
it how are they gonna do it you know we
went into the 2016 i think it was one of
those games maybe it's been 2015. i'm
the years are starting to blur together
on me uh but when the steelers faced the
patriots right out of the gates and
there was this concern how do you cover
gronk how do you cover gronk i mean
that's probably a question that's been
ricocheting around the texans defensive
meeting room as it relates to covering
travis kelsey no doubt about it i mean
yes he's such a safety net in the middle
of the field when mahomes is in trouble
oh the pocket's collapsing i don't know
what to do
you know he's got like that that i don't
even know what to say that connection
with kelsey where you're like whoa i
don't know how they pulled that off
somehow mahome wanted him to go that way
and he knew and he went that way
now the other guy to mention i think for
the texans defense or we didn't would be
zach cunningham that's why they just
paid him a lot of money because i think
they think he can be that type of guy
middle linebacker
plays all three downs you know he can
thump in between the tackles but his
real bread and butter is the ability to
cover you know tight ends and backs out
of the backfield so i would imagine if
they match up
he's he could have that duty a few times
whether they got him matched up on
kelsey or maybe clyde edward hillaire
out of the backfield but again there you
go it's gonna be they'll be able to run
games with those two now in the middle
of the field zones over unders here
there's kelsey you know up top there's
clyde edwards hilaire below there's just
uh so many things you got to worry about
in this kansas city offense
kelsey in the playoff game
had 10 catches on 12 targets for 134
yards and three touchdowns and he had
two drops so right 12 for 12. he was
open
and and the thing about patrick holmes
and travis kelsey they've got that
brady and welker vibe radiant edelman
vibe that that kelsey is the guy who's
always around mahomes anytime off field
remember when texas tech was playing in
the final four a year and a half ago
travis kelsey didn't go to texas tech
but patrick was right excellent kelsey's
there in the stands with him kelsey will
not let mahomes out of his sight and
it's worked and and they they know
they've got that connection they've got
that ability to finish each other's
sentences one guy's gonna know where the
other guy's gonna be and you do it
enough over and over and over again it
starts to click it starts to mesh it
becomes unspoken it becomes automatic it
becomes unstoppable that's right that's
that's camaraderie that's knowing your
teammate being around a guy you know
all of it yeah i got the camaraderie
camaraderie yeah uh yeah but that's all
of it that's you know spending time with
a guy there's the little nuances of
football that make a connection special
you know
last year in that game there was a
number of plays where kelsey got the
catch and got 15 20 yards and he was
double covered but mahomes was like ah
he'll figure this out he's worked on
that we've worked on this before we're
not the first team to get double covered
travis kelsey and bam but i do think
there is something to all that what you
just said i mean they were playing beer
pong against post malone this year he
doesn't leave patrick mahomes side he's
very smart that way and yeah he's
developed a special connection with him
and i can't remember who it was one of
the two was very bad at beer pong and
the other one was very good and it
resulted in post malone drinking a whole
lot of beer before he started he got it
he got the autographed tattoo of mahomes
on his face or something i believe
because mahomes kept beating them in
beer pong and opposed supposedly post
malone takes his beer pong game very
seriously
and mahomes kept beating them and they
went like okay you beat me this time i'm
going to get a tattoo of your autograph
on me and mahomes beat him and he got an
autograph of patrick bombs and i believe
travis kelsey kelsey on his body
apparently post malone takes his beer
pong even more seriously than he takes
his shows at least as it relates to not
being drunk when you go out on the stage
if he was i don't know you're supposed
to be if you're a rock star aren't you i
mean it sounds like i don't know
that doesn't sound fun drunk before
drunk during drunk after driving all the
time all right uh when the texans have
the football you've got deshawn watson
you don't have deandre hopkins but
you've got will fuller and kenny stills
and brandon cooks and it's trending in
the right direction for cooks to play
tonight diversification of the offense
not having that one guy that becomes the
focal point darius leonard the colts
told me last year after they beat the
texans hey it was a key play it was
fourth down we knew where the ball was
going it's going to hopkins he's their
guy this year maybe it's a greater
mystery maybe it makes desean watson
better maybe it's addition by
subtraction who knows it was a stunner
when they traded the andre hopkins what
do we really expect they got david
johnson who can have a little bit of a
career rebirth in houston they've got
receivers that are going to be more of a
non-go-to guy throw to the guy who's
open do we see deshaun watson stepping
up into that role i do i think so i
think he's he's too smart of a human
being and knows too much about the sport
to realize like hey it can't just be me
and one guy trying to figure it out you
know play after play game after game and
we're gonna carry the passing offense i
i expect the the texans offense to be
one of the more dangerous units in
football this year i really do you know
one i think their offensive line issues
are figured out they did a great job in
last year's draft of not you know
knocking out of the park with their
first two picks so i think they're
solidified there to where now watson
doesn't always have to like look out of
the corner of his eye look at the pass
rush do those things but to me
it is the
oh and i know we've talked about you
can't pin any of these guys to one
specific thing within the offense it's a
little bit like let's just say
uh amendola chris hogan and julian
edelman in new england right to where
you're like man they're all kind of the
same guy and you know i don't know which
guy's gonna do which on this play yeah
they kind of use them all in in every
facet of the pass offense and i think
that's what you're gonna have in a lot
of ways here too you know randall cobb's
part of the bunch too to where you're
not going to be able to go oh it's third
and five they're in this formation
they're going to go to this person no i
think it's going to be bored by
committee and then they got david
johnson coming out of the back field
this year that's going to change things
too so i really am looking for a huge
year and i think houston you know i
think we can sit here too rashad
breeland kansas city he's not playing
there's questions in that kansas city
secondary can they match up across the
board against this unit with houston and
i expect them to move the ball and put
up some points tonight too
let me dust off a narrative that we will
revisit from time to time as it relates
to dealing with a team with a
high-powered offense yeah
keep that team on the sidelines as long
as you possibly can right that one how
do you avoid a 51 to 7 run
you make sure that when you have the
ball you use every second of the play
clock you call plays that will gain 4
and 5 yards not 14 and 15 yards you take
your time moving the ball down the field
i mean as bill o'brien who's a damn good
coach in his own right went back to the
lab for the past several months knowing
that he was going to have to go to
kansas city again and then finding out
it was going to be the first game out of
the gates doesn't it make sense to think
that you're going to design your offense
when you're facing a team that can drop
51
in two and a two and two-thirds quarters
that you're going to do what you can to
limit the number of times that offense
has the ball which means keeping the
ball as long as possible when you have
it well billy o'brien he's always been
pretty good with being patient with the
run you know yeah to me that that's a
good question mike i mean they're built
to score and go they really are
you know to me
i i i think the the more the adjustment
part of what houston does here
yeah maybe they can play more of the
conservative passing game and decide
they want to run the ball and do that
but i think that the advantage the
texans have is they can look at their
games from last year and go okay we got
to scrap the defensive game plan that's
the first thing we got to do they move
the ball it will will on us in two games
so obviously we got to change our whole
approach the schematical approach what
we're going to do in certain situations
how we match up but i i'll be interested
mike i think that's a very good question
i mean would he do that i i have a hard
time believing he would with watson and
this group and everything like that that
he'd want to play that style of football
but maybe tonight's the night you do it
because you just don't feel good about
your defense in week one no preseason
and you know you're you're playing the
greatest show on turf there in kansas
city it's a good question i don't know
if i have an exact answer for you there
carlos i was a leading rusher in the
playoff game last year for the texans 13
carries 44 yards it was a little bit
different though but because
you know the 21 the 24 came so easily to
them big pass playing
yeah and and then and then the track
meet was on right so it's not like you
can shift to grind the clock and get out
of dodge mode but uh yeah and that's
everything too apart from what the
texans do with the ball or what the
chiefs do with the ball when you've got
the chance to deliver the knockout blow
we saw it in january and who knows maybe
the chiefs would have come back from 28
nothing down but i think psychologically
there's a huge difference between 28-0
and 24-0 they had the chance to go up
28-0 they decided uh ultimately to kick
the field goal and you just wonder in
those moments and football games come
down to a moment here a moment there a
decision here a decision there a bounce
of the ball here a bounce of the ball
there that it feels like well we know it
would ultimately would have been a
different challenge for the chiefs if
they were down 28 nothing but but that
felt like the moment that the texans
became aware the the old analogy of when
you're beating your big brother in ping
pong and you're not supposed to be and
you become aware that you're winning and
you get nervous that feels like the
moment where the texans were like holy
crap and they got nervous and they got
conservative and if it would have been
28 nothing who knows what would have
happened well yeah i i mean it's about
it's a valid point certainly you know i
mean yeah i watched the game you know
all these reruns have been on so much
during the year and there's no football
i watched the game was on again the
other night you know there they were
they were getting ready to go for it up
21-0 it was fourth and one you know it
was really probably fourth and a half of
the yard but they couldn't get the play
in on time they called the timeout and
then he decided to kick the field goal i
think he just came away going you know
what you know let me make this a 24
point game yeah you know it's it's three
two point conversion touchdowns or a
four score game um also though let's not
forget this aspect
billy o'brien first off is a hell of a
coach we know that you could say what
you want the gm all that but every year
doesn't matter who the team has had a
quarterback or whatever it's like oh
houston's in the playoffs who's their
quarterback holy cow they're in there
now he's really got something
but
he'll be able to sell to his team like
we can go in there and beat them you
know obviously we know we just talked
about they beat him in the regular
season last year but even into that
playoff game mike you know let's not
forget billy o'brien he'll probably be
able to sell to his team like hey i made
a stupid fake punt call right when it
was 24 to 7 or 24 to 8 whatever that was
he's going to probably tell them i
shouldn't have done that and then on the
ensuing after the chief scored the
touchdown to make it 24-14 or whatever
it was
they fumbled the kick return and gave
the kansas city chiefs the ball back on
like the 10-yard line so he's going to
look at those things going here like hey
guys i know they're great blah blah blah
blah blah blah but we kind of gave them
the the kickstart they needed to get
that going there we don't do that who
knows where the game's going to go and i
think he'll be able to sell that to his
players a little bit and his players
will look at it and go yeah you know two
three plays different who knows what the
hell happens in that football game and i
think they can go in there and kind of
clean slate and have some confidence
that they can pull this off tonight
would you show your team more of the
film from the regular season win 31-24
when they were down 17-3 and withstood
that barrage out of the gates or film
from the loss which one would you lean
on more to convince them they can go in
there and win oh well i think i think
that first game is always you know any
time you've done it you can go in there
and take away the positive that game and
and sell that to your team in a team
meeting and look like hey we went in
here look here's a big third down to
sean watson he answered the bell hey we
had to stop my homes in a third down hey
look at defense we did it we know we can
do this you know so i think you build on
that and then you go to go
all right now let's look at the playoff
game and let's look at some of the dumb
things we did and the mistakes we made
and yes we lost you know 51 to blah blah
blah but man these three four plays if
we just do our jobs or hold the ball or
i'm not stupid and call a fake punt
you know it could be a different story
and i think guys first off guys are
always looking for a reason to believe
in a locker room and i think this is
truly one of those reasons that you know
you could believe
to finish where we started with the
basketball analogy back in the days when
i actually watched a lot of basketball
and enjoyed a lot of basketball because
i wasn't 100 football all the time there
were those games where you would be
going up against a team that you know is
going to go on a run at some point you
just know it right you just know if
there's going to be an 18 to 2 run at
some point in this game can you
otherwise do what you need to do to
withstand it because it's coming and
that's how you have to view the chiefs
it's coming whether it's 17-3 out of the
gates which the texans overcame or 51-7
and now but you know half of that right
right what you does it become 51 to
seven that's really the challenge when
it starts can you stop the bleeding can
you get it to end and flip it around and
find a way to recover from it you have
to accept when you play the chiefs
it's coming at some point you can never
get comfortable you can never get
complacent you can never get confident
even if there's only seven minutes left
in the super bowl there's always a
chance the explosion is going to be
there and you have to be ready for it
chris at any time and no doubt i think
there's no team in the nfl that knows
that better than texans no there isn't
they should at least they yeah they've
experienced it they've seen it i mean
you're right even in that win i mean
they were on they were teetering on like
oh whoa we might get blown out of the
you know the the chief stadium here but
you know to me the the thing you're
talking about that run and all that
you're right i mean kansas city's going
to do that
who is going to be that player is it jj
watt or somebody else that can make a
play on the defensive side of the ball
to you know stalemate that run or slow
it down put some ice on it okay nope
you're not going down for the third
second consecutive time to score a
touchdown you know that's to me where
kansas city has the advantage because
kansas city's got chris jones and frank
clark and honey badger all guys who can
make plays to change a football game in
a heartbeat to where kansas city doesn't
need to be you know like we talked about
the steel curtain or the purple people
eaters or anything like that they kind
of have an exotic defense they do a lot
of different things and i think they go
one of our guys one of these big time
big timers is gonna make a play to just
give us one more possession and that's
where we're gonna win the game because
our offense will go down and score and
that's where they're they're kind of
great that way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports